It's Always Sunny In the City of wrexham  on Friday the Welsh Borough was  conferred City status by King Charles  while he was there he met the local  soccer team which is owned by actors  Ryan Reynolds best known for playing the  Marvel character Deadpool and Rob  mcelaney the star of the comedy series  It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia they  were joined by wrexham AFC players as  well as members of a soccer league whose  players use electric wheelchairs well  done well done has anybody watched that  show no not yet no I talked this I  haven't either but I talked to somebody  I talked to somebody who said they  really enjoyed it we will put it on the  list there you go